tu entends ce message puis l'année notre
situer les uns et les autres
tu peux les trouver bientôt il n'y
aurait plus aucun enfant nulle part le
gouvernement n'avait pas peur de ceux
qui étaient morts ils avaient peur de
nous car ceux qui avaient survécu avait
changé
rugby les jeunes comme toi sont vraiment
rares j'ai fait partie des plus
puissants
là où on pas les jeunes vivent ensemble
est libre et celles qui sont prêts à
nous aider
seydoux
surtout tu t'arrêtes pas
pour leur sécurité la vôtre vous devez
nous livrer vos enfants je suis assez
malin pour voir que tu caches quelque
chose est assez maligne pour le kg je
voulais pas que vous ayez peur de moi
plus je sais de me contrôler
plus je deviens dangereux aussi
je peux aider à maîtriser des facultés
pour que tu puisse s'en servir
[Musique]
opus battre
et
on n'est plus obligé de se cacher
on a survécu à tout ça
qui me battrai pour nous tous
[Musique]
je sais qui vous êtes vous êtes l'avocat
c'est eux qui ont tué votre famille
n'ont eux c'est mon père
pantalon
et maintenant vous les traquer
alios
on a des preuves que les cartes elles
aident les terroristes à passer la
frontière
président ajoute les cartels de la
drogue la liste des organisations
terroristes vous imaginez bien que ça va
nous permettre d'étendre notre champ
d'action pour les combattre voulait en
finir avec tout ça
valoir me laisser me salir les mains
c'est exactement pour cette poussette
nous aider à déclencher une guerre
contre qui
tout non
pas de limite cette fois
la première fois
votre objectif c'était de déclencher une
guerre entre les cartels mexicains
pas contre le gouvernement mexicain
cette cabine a été témoin de l'émission
c'est bien ça oui monsieur on ne peut
pas risquer qu'elles tombent entre de
mauvaises mains
faites le ménage il me demande de rompre
les liens débarrasse toi d'elle je peux
pas faire ça ne me met pas dans cette
situation fait ce que tu as à faire je
vais avoir besoin d'une équipe de choc
de deux hélicos et de drones de combat
au coup d'état c'est où
pour mexique
une raison de me faire confiance
d'avoir confiance en moi te permettra de
rester
bonne chance la chance n'existe pas ce
côté de la frontière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
car par les tic tac
[Musique]
bonjour tu es lewis je présume
tu verras cet endroit est tout à fait
surprenant
[Musique]
cette maison a été construite il ya
extrêmement l'autre
[Musique]
il y à une horloge gâcher dans les murs
dans le doute
on ne sait pas à quoi elle sert
à part que c'est effrayant
alors tu as tout raconter à lewis ah bah
non pas tout
[Musique]
tu peux aller visiter il n'y a
absolument aucun danger
6 en danger ce truc tant qu'il a le
ventre plat
[Musique]
la dynamite soit faire tant sur toi
merci
attention
[Musique]
ici le monde entier est à nos pieds
michael nous en sommes fiers
vous allez devenir médecin oui c'est ma
passion
christopher meyer crise est grand
reporter pour la société presque porte
on a tous nos vieux amis et aux nouveaux
à nice une femme très bien piqué grâce à
vous je me sens comme chez moi elle est
très attachée à toi ça se voit
ça devient très dangereux pour les
arméniens ici alors je veux que tu
partes ici si je ne suis pas en sécurité
ici alors mon peuple non plus je reste
ban qu'est ce que la société presse fait
ici on rapporte les seuils de la guerre
ce n'est pas la guerre
[Musique]
personne ici n'est sans résoudre qu'ils
veulent notre mort
[Musique]
il faut qu'on s'évade de turquie avant
qu'il ne soit trop tard
déçu que vous organisez des filières
d'évasion pour les orphelins dites moi
ce que je peux faire
[Musique]
est ce que tu aimes
et
attraper ces legs couette
et à trop d'espions
[Musique]
christ
ensemble nous construirons un avenir
[Musique]
cela fait la course s'appelait tire deux
fois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mister jingle smic je n'ai jamais vu
comme ça vous savez ça parce qu'il a
fait mif son mip était pourtant clair on
t'a bien eu branche les paupiettes
[Musique]
effet qu'il veut du dessert génial je
sais qu'il m'arrive de dire ça après
coup de tout un tas de choses mais cette
fois ci je le pense vraiment qu'elle
choque rôle en avant la musique
je présente laurent faure maire d'evry
ah oui
elle est morte mais sérieusement vas
t'amuser un peu moi je vais sortir avec
mes copines ok mais fais attention à toi
et les plus importants pour l'asb d'une
marine
ma soeur s'est fait enlever
je vous promets de faire tout ce que je
pourrai pour retrouver mire vous avez vu
ce que font ces [ __ ]
ce sont des experts cdu quarantaine il
j'essaie de trouver la trace du
fournisseur mais apparemment le client
celui faut laisser les flics faire leur
travail et ne retrouveront pas brandon
on va faire quoi
partir en guerre
il ya plus qu elle qui compte
votre frère brandon vous avez fait
l'armée n'est ce pas ce qu'ils font est
à la fois illégal et dangereux
je ne peux rien faire aussi vous avez 24
heures
saïd et peut-être que je devrais
ça fait partie de notre famille c'est ça
notre famille
il va nous emmener jusqu'à elle ouais je
vous emmènerai jusqu'à elle
je m'en fous de mourir
fou d'ailleurs en prison
je passerai pas les bras tant que
j'aurai pas retrouvé
mesdames et messieurs le vainqueur coton
de te revoir
il est temps pour toi de défendre ton
titre lors d'un nouveau au papa maman ou
du passera le reste de ta vie en prison
je te présente non qu est un spécimen
d'humains supérieur plus grand plus fort
que n'importe quel être humain sur cette
planète
ça arrivera pas il faut qu'on trouve un
moyen de faire avancer les choses
ils ont kidnappé sa femme il faut que tu
commences à t'entraîner
l'homme le plus fort ne gagnent pas
toujours le plus intelligent 6
la force contre sa faiblesse
et sa faiblesse c'est une bonne question
et tu es suffira de t'asseoir
et de profiter du voyage
allez viens
ta interrompu ma méditation ça t'aide à
rester calme tirez pas mon nom est
docteur william moulton marston et je
suis le créateur de wonder woman wonder
woman est une lettre d'amour
[Musique]
une personne est plus heureuse si elle
est soumise à une autorité qu'elle
affectionne j'ai envie de l'étudier elle
va te briser le coeur ne serait pas
jalouse je suis ton épouse battage au
lien je crois que vous avez envie d'une
vie non conventionnés peut-être que je
la veux seulement parce que tulle
quoi c'est possible des mythes de
personnes en même temps
[Musique]
qu'est ce que la normalité ce que nous
voulons pourra jamais se complique
le monde latéral
[Musique]
le monde ne peut pas nous en empêcher
est ce que c'est ce que tu veux dans
tous les numéros de wonder woman
les femmes sont fous et tfc enchaîné
ligoté bâillonné comportement anormal
dans les pages de votre comité de la
conscience
une femme ne pourra jamais recevoir sa
liberté jusqu'à ce qu'elle l'acquiert
récit qui tient absolument à comprendre
l'esprit d'une femme commence avec ça
tu es brillante elle a un coeur pur ball
intention d' à vous de vous êtes la
femme parfaite prenant oman a une
identité secrète pour quelles raisons
elle doit cacher sa vraie personnalité
au monde que je peux être utile si
l'identité secrète de wonder woman était
ravie tout serait perdu je me demande si
ce n'est pas plutôt vos qu'il y avait
une identité secrète
[Musique]
par ce fonds
préfet et non car ta nature est factice
merci
[Musique]
en ce moment venu
eminem
et
[Musique]
mackenzie
on
[Musique]
je vous proposais avec champagne chez
d'orange savais que mon appel un
cocktail à base de champagne et une
orange
oui on me mazars aux lèvres elle forme
un coeur là c'est très joli
mais nous on se revoit quand dans une
autre vie
[Musique]
salut rigueur et damien j'ai pas bien
prendre un petit café ou la wet ne tombe
pas cooking d'amiens ca c est qu aujourd
hui scarpetta
je me suis réveillé un beau matin dans
une société adhérente tués dans un
univers parallèle où les femmes me
disais que je devais faire
[Musique]
c'est pas fini non marchand et est ce
qu'un paquebot monde
la grand chose pour que tout les projets
voient le jour
bonjour vous savez qu'on appelle à un
cocktail à base de champagne et du gange
mimosas sais quoi je demande si t'as pas
un problème normal met un petit
complément là c'est plus possible
à temps
l'habitude fait que pour débarrasser les
meurtres mais elle
j'ai une trouille c'est que disparaisse
imaginez un monde où ce sont les femmes
qui se font belles pour moi c'est moi
qui leur fait des compliments
quelle horreur
toi tu as raison
[Musique]
l'amour c'est l'essence de la vie
c'est puissant magique et merveilleux
jusqu'au moment où tout s'arrête suis
pas heureuse quoi ok dix mois ce qui va
posthume langue c'est la personne que
j'ai rencontrée ya trois ans ce gala
était romantique romantique
tu paies sous mon nez je m'hydrate tu
devrais contents pour moi
shi végétarienne au mais je mange du
poisson et le pepperoni sur la pizza
parce que ça compte pas
[Musique]
c'est monsieur washington à vos cannes a
dit l'avocat
seulement mon frère c'est quand tu seras
morte j'ai pas dit ça je t'ai entendu je
le pensais pas c'est trop dur ça ne
l'est pas forcément je veux juste être
heureusement on ne dit pas se laisser
glisser amoureux ont dû tomber amoureux
parce que oui c'est douloureux mais tu
le sauras jamais si tu ne jette pas de
cette falaise
je pensais que les mariages arrangés
c'était scandaleux mais je commence à me
dire que c'est peut-être la moins pire
des solutions je veux dire oh regarde
tes parents tout était arrangé et son
super heureux mes parents se sont
rencontrés en fac de médecine
ouais ouais
tulle m et alors et alors tu vas le
laisser partir sans réagir
arrête de tenir comme ça trouve un truc
plus simple peut-être que molly moins
d'être aux différents genres moi je vois
le verre d'eau à moitié plein ll voile
ou empoisonné
écoute tu imagines pas toute la pression
que j'ai sur les épaules pour toi c'est
facile mais je peux pas avoir un bébé
quand je serais tellement mieux que
j'arriverai même pas le titre est le
plus heureux des hommes si tu avais une
excuse pour pas le porter
[Musique]